all right so I end each podcast by
letting the guests ask me one question
and before I let you do that I'll give
you a second to think I have to comment
because I have been impressed with your
gif game on Twitter for those of you
that don't know Jim is is quite active
on Twitter and over the last couple of
weeks all of a sudden it's like he
discovered the the gif feature and has
been lighting the internet on fire and
and I have literally laughed out loud a
few times when I've seen that things
that you've posted well thank you look I
I think that you know here's another
thing that I've found is that most of
the smartest people I've ever met and
I've met a lot of people in my life I've
been very very blessed and lucky most of
the smartest people I've met in life
have a good sense of humor mm-hmm and
and and that's for two reasons right
because a good sense of humor also sees
the dark side right and so I figure
gifts if we can't laugh have a little
fun you know what what's a day for all
right
the question that I have for you is why
did you abandon your logo that I retag
onto your messages
oh the virus is spreading I love that
the virus is spreading with with the
rocket all right so because you're
asking I will I will let one of my
secrets go so I think of Twitter as a
combination between conversations that
we're all having on the internet as
characters of ourselves right yeah and
so if you were to look at Twitter
through the lens of WWE for example
right right and I asked you I said you
know who is the hero who is the you know
villain who is the kind of that the
clowny person right and and who is the
announcer and you could probably say
that first it kind of fits that that
character right and so the first time
that I said it was
intentional in kind of any grand plan
but the logic on how things go
of course the the logic behind it was
everyone's worried about the technology
right but what what was fascinating me
and I think you know why I'm drawn to a
lot of things that you're thinking about
is the psychological element of this it
was capturing the mental energy of
everyone right across every industry
across every age demographic Geographic
locate I mean just every it's a good
meme right very good me and when it was
I was like this is this is viral right
and in the sense of kind of from the
technology world but it's spreading like
a virus cuz no one can stop it right
when a product goes viral you can
basically pull the plug and stop the
growth with a virus a lot of times you
can't stop it and so I was like you know
the virus is spreading and the internet
lit up right and people kept saying it
over and over again you were off for a
little while and you came back and I saw
that you didn't have it and I actually
put it on well the reason so so when I
came back there was two things as to why
and it wasn't again not even really
intentional but when I took when I took
the Twitter break what I realized was it
just Twitter specifically and I was
during a drawdown it was you know do all
those stuff you're I think that a little
more sobriety well the pro in the condom
of all of this playing out digitally
right and kind of on Twitter is is this
idea that somebody can come up with a
thought a thesis you know whatever throw
it out into the open yeah and there's
people from all walks of life all
perspectives all levels of success and
failure and they just attack right true
now true the good part of that is the
law of attrition takes over and so the
ideas that can withstand those attacks
are usually the strongest and have the
most merit and kind of end up persisting
over some long period of time but
there's a lot of ideas that never make
it to the levee attrition you know
there's a guy on
Twitter who I follow and actually
support his work he's called mimetic
value okay and he has a really
interesting deck about you know John
Campbell's the hero's journey yep and
how you know every story that we hear is
like one of six but one of his ideas is
there always has to be a scapegoat and
he talks about how the scapegoat Steve
Jobs turned into the hero and it's
really interesting I'll send you the
link because I think you'd enjoy
following and for sure
Twitter is a is one of the places where
again I think human psychology
incentives just play out perfectly you
know it is the world's largest
psychology experiment ever conducted and
we still know how it's gonna turn out
fifty years from now when they are when
they are going through the data and they
see your gifts you're gonna you're gonna
throw sand in the wheels there